oops we kind of explore those tropes and
kind of try and bring them alive in the
game and suffered yeah movies like ghost
ship and triangle you know that sense of
isolation
of being trapped in a location and not
being able to to get out of it so that
just thing I think that one of the
things was the idea of the sea as a kind
of dark powerful force there's lots of
myths announced that the seed sailors
have we always like to start from four
myths or from often urban myths of urban
legends as some little bit of truth in
the world so that was that was where we
started and then he was about fleshing
out their world and working out finding
the characters that was really important
to to work out what the counters in our
story were gonna be like and how they
would interact with that world and
its mysterious and no one has worked out
what happened
on that ship so this was an opportunity
to
to tell our version of that story it's a
completely new narrative there'd be new
characters and you get a new cast there
is one character that appears in all the
dark picture stories and that's the
curator that's this guy who introduces
the story and
at key points in the story he'll talk
straight to you and he'll kind of
comment on your progress or give you
hints
he's kind of quite strange character but
he's very much his own character he's a
he's a he's a bit more sinister than the
psychiatrist but yeah he he appears and
he talked directly to you in the same
way if it's a big branching narrative
game like until dawn was you'll be
making choices you'll be exploring
environments
trying to get your characters out alive
yes we learn a huge amount from until
dawn about how to make the soar game and
how to make a scary game and we've taken
all that knowledge and brought it over
into our yeah there's a bunch of new
features
there are new ways of interacting in the
world
one thing we always try to do is how do
we put you into that story
how do we when you interact with the
controller how does that carry through
into into the world of the game so
we've got some new new covenants of
actions we got heartbeat mechanic where
you have to kind of control your
heartbeat we've got a button mash
mechanical you have to push things open
so we've got those new attractions and
we've got a new ways of tracking
the character relationships of the
traits and things like that so you can
explore how you've affected the way
those characters feel about each other
that was a kind this is all about the
subgenres we explore the connoisseurs of
horror and
yeah that kind of monster movie was
where ultimately until dawn was this is
about this is Goshen so so yeah haunted
ship
and you find out the secrets of that
yeah so I play a character named Conrad
who's
kind of well off
American 20-something is very brash it's
very confident and he rubs some people
the wrong way which is what Tom was just
talking about he has an interaction with
some local fisherman and he just kind of
acts like
not the nicest guy in the world and
instigates some of the some of the
actions that sort of lead them to this
ghost ship essentially
and that's kind of what I liked about
this character he I've never quite
played a guy like him he's the kind of
character that people will either love
or hate which is good I think for a
story like this and also for a survival
story and a bit of a detective story
like you know you're the characters the
players have to navigate this
environment and interact with everything
and
Conrad has no filter he says everything
that comes to his mind whether it's the
right thing to say or not and so it was
a very fun character to play because he
can be rude he can be funny all at the
same time which is what was interesting
as an actor so usually you play you know
you get a script a film or television
script and there's only one story
there's one version of the character
with Conrad and with all the characters
in the game
the character shifts depending on the
choices the the player makes so for
example you know there's a heroic
version of Conrad in this story and
there's also potentially a cowardly
version of Conrad in the story as an
actor you get to explore both sides of
that and so the player as they choose
what Conrad does he becomes a different
character within that players experience
oh absolutely every character can
survive and every character can die yeah
you play as a whole bunch of
characters
conquer
goddamn is our main characters but uh
yeah you but you play he plays a whole
bunch of any one of five characters they
can all live with all they can all die
and you never know when that's going to
happen so you never you can never quite
relax because because death is kind of
everywhere with the game
it kind of is because you just you just
you know you never know you always want
you touch even tiny little decisions
you have to think really hard about
because ultimately you could get
yourself killed so
so just the whole the seeds can play out
differently depending on we've done
earlier in the game and then we don't
know who's gonna be alive and who's
gonna be in dead so those n DS could be
different depending on who's alive and
who's dead and who gets away and who
doesn't so it's there are a huge number
of possibilities for the Ender's ends of
crazy units that's some crazy weird
argument earlier there was one I'm not
gonna spoil it but there was one ending
that they told us about at the end and I
was like I cannot believe
they're all there's there's a lot of
crazy endings there's some happiness not
happening but there's one in particular
well I was just like I can't believe
what I love very creative very
interesting no the runtime is between
four and five hours and you'll always
get that four or five hours and you'll
always get a really good story but it
might it won't be the same as anyone
elses story quite so
yeah it's it's four or five hours we
think I'll replay value is very high so
that that's the thing we love mantled or
as soon as people play it they they get
to the ending and then they go back and
they try and change the things that that
they did and try get a different ending
and we really tried to uh we really
tried to enable and one of the reasons
why Sean had a script that was literally
that money they hear me scream it was
like a little housing ages so we thought
about all the different ways that you
could play it when you go back you you
make different choices you'll genuinely
get sometimes hole seeds will be there
or not there
different or they'll play out in a very
very different way so we think there's a
huge amount of replayability and people
will have you know people have fun just
going back in trying out different
things finding new new content
we're confident people will enjoy doing
them and one of the cool things is that
we get the player thinking themselves
you know they're looking at the world
and they're working out without us
having to tell them and then they find
things in the world and they can you
know read about something on a bit pay
for find an object and they can relay
that to the rest of the world so bad
that keeps players really gaze that sort
of storytelling again as a beacon being
a detective there's no there's a bunch
of the stuff you can click so we got
that we got secrets which are things in
the world which will tell you a tiny bit
of information about the backstory and
on its own that bit of information isn't
much good but when you find a load of
them you can piece things together this
is the detective thing and you work out
what's going on and that can help me
survive and we also have these
premonitions these are pictures that you
find in the world they give you a tiny
glimpse of a possible future and and the
idea is that can if you can work out how
that can help you then that can you know
you can use that to your own good yeah
it's about giving different styles of
gameplay over that runtime so sometimes
it's an exploration
sometimes it's it's kind of discussing
and choosing what to do and it's making
sure those those things where you can
find out things about the story I'll
spread throughout the game you know so
some even quite late on you'll be
finding out new stuff maybe that will
make sense of things that happened a
long time ago other games in the in the
dark beaches anthology will be
standalone games and they were some of
them already in development yeah I think
you'll finish this you get whichever
ending you'll do your replayability and
we hope you'll like that type of game
and you'll be connected with it with the
dark pitches universe we have put in
some
connecting strands between the games
kind of Easter eggs that you can
spot things
similarities and things between the game
so we think people have fun finding that
sort of soccer first and foremost I
loved the
concept I love the story I love the
genre so that was kind of what brought
me in and then I looked at the character
and I was like okay this is
again I look at Conrad as an instigator
and he's not I've never played a
character like Conrad so again first
foremost I was like I love what
supermassive does I liked what until
dawn was and so I just wanted to be part
of that and when I'm choosing roles and
games I want bold storytelling and I
want
really narrative
performance-driven characters and
stories and that's why I think
supermassive does and that's what this
did and then it was like okay I'll just
jump in with Conrad and just have fun
and truly it's a fun character it's it's
almost a larger-than-life character and
that was a lot of fun to play with in
the context of this crazy scary scary
story some of my favorite scenes to play
were before things get too scary and
again I don't I don't want to spoil too
much because I don't think we've
directly shown it but he's just
he's a bit of an [__]
house it but that's what's fun and again
part of the way that this story
gets started is because of Conrad's
actions he's not trying to do anything
wrong he just finds himself on the wrong
side of the wrong people and he also
considers himself a ladies man which is
kind of funny so he's constantly trying
to hit on one of the characters and it's
awkward sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't so yeah those are so those are
some of my favorite scenes just getting
to know the character and getting to
know the other characters before it all
gets crazy and then it gets really
important in specifically in the horror
genre like you have to care about the
characters you have to understand who
they are and how they approach the world
so that when you get into these
heightened situations
you can sort of project how they're
gonna do things you want to understand
that so it's not completely
unpredictable from a character
standpoint hugely challenging to work
with with the branching narrative
because you have to try to keep track of
all these
story branching narrative story points
and character points and again what if a
player just makes one decision for
Conrad it makes him
that influences who he becomes his
general demeanor with other characters
or just how he's seen by other
characters as well so it's hard to keep
track of all that but but the guy's
super massive guys really helped us out
by tracking that by having literally
like flow charts so remember we made
this decision here which led to this
decision so when we're in this scene
this is how you're interacting with
these characters they see you this way
or you're mad at this person or or you
could be
injured so don't forget like you have to
play pain in this scene only if you've
made these decisions if you didn't make
these decisions you get to this point of
the game and you're not injured so very
complex and complicated to try to track
all that but that's also part of the fun
of it mocha process keeps getting better
and better and it and it and it becomes
better for the actors as well so so we
were we've sent you over the kind of
headset on and when were you able to
walk around oh yeah it was we getting
the facial capture is incredibly
accurate so we can get tiny nuances of
performance and that's great for us
because we want to make cinematic type
games cinematic quality we got a great
guys back at the studio very talented
audio lighting guys camera guys and then
if you give them a really great
performance you know that's that's what
they need to make it great we can so we
set up a center stage and we kind of
have the lights on them we have the
morning a moment in the middle with the
scripts and it's you know it's kind of
we kind of acting it out in as an
environment familiar to them as possible
it's quite intense shoot yeah I think
and it said we have to get through a lot
of material and a sure said it very
complicated
but yeah it's worth it to get those
performances to so that sir please have
really engaged with those characters
really care about those characters and
then they can get scared when they care
about people and you want them to
survive then you get scared I think the
best part for me too was having the
actors there and all the actors so have
so you can work off after every time so
just to go back to the the technology
when I did quantum break the cameras
that we were using the head rigs were a
little more cumbersome and much bigger
so now a few years later when I'm doing
Menem again the cameras were much
smaller lighter easier so you felt less
so really the ease the Cole thing about
it was when I'm acting with another
actor I can look into their face I mean
we're looking at each other you have to
stay a little ways apart because the
camera is kind of come up front so you
can't get too close to each other but
you can be looking in someone's face and
sharing that performance and feeding off
each other which it's totally you can
achieve a performance just by yourself
or the mocap thing and acting off of
nobody but there is there something that
you you will miss if you don't have all
the actors in one space being able to
look at each other and even just have a
conversation about what the scene is
like discuss what that moment is and
adjust to it I felt like we were very
free to
to not change things but but if
something's not working for us have that
discussion with with the the creative
people just to make it work for us and
ultimately you're all trying to
put your input to create the character
to create the story and to make it work
and I think that's that that that
chemistry that you can't really control
it just has to happen when you're they
are all working to try to tell the story
and create the best moments possible a
motion capture stage is just a big
warehouse like there's not much to it
but they they had like these look books
for us so we can see what the ship was
going to look like and also like rough
videos
like certain environments and it makes a
difference like if you're in the cargo
hold of a ship well is it 40 feet wide
or 40 feet tall do if they yell at each
other or can we speak you know how loud
is this room it's the engine room how
loud is that none of that's there so
it's all created by the team and then we
have to sort of try to implement that
and they're often it was you know the
direction wasn't like about the
performance or the nuance of her
performance it was like you have to
speak louder you know you know you're
running faster you know just things like
that physicalities that you don't have
an emotion capture stage that you would
have on a traditional film stage like
well they're standing 40 feet away I
know how loud I have to speak to them
but when you're in a small stage
standing next to each other you
sometimes have to be reminded remember
you guys are yelling at each other you
know there's this much distance and so
we had those images and if we didn't
have that they knew what the
environments were going to look like so
they could explain that to us and
sometimes we have to really think like
movie directors you know we get so we
can't do it in Reverse how it moves is
if we get all our data and then we get
that into a game engine and then we put
cameras in it and that gives us a lot of
freedom it means we can move cameras
around the only shooting a movie that's
it you're like yeah
but we can move cameras around quite
creatively afterwards but certainly
that's where we take our inspiration
from that expertise that comes from
movies and from lighting and that is
something that the audience is really
familiar with that's the language they
understand our off cuts and lighting and
how cameras are set so yeah absolutely
we're influenced by that
and we want people to be able to engage
with it on that level it's been a good
experience going mosque platform we're
very excited to be able to to bring our
games and these kind of punchy narrative
choice driven games to Xbox and PC and
to Sony
so yeah it's exciting for us to be able
to broaden the audience like that and
it's been a very positive experience